really excited to be here too
- all about building decentralized or
peer-to-peer applications I recently
built one with a couple friends and it
was my first time doing so and it was a
real learning learning opportunity for
me I think like paradigm shift is a
really dramatic word but definitely
opened my eyes to different ways of
building applications which was cool
so I want to take you on that journey
with me a little bit of going from like
not knowing very much at all about
something to knowing a bit more so the
way we're gonna do that is we're going
to take this big concept of
decentralisation and kind of anchor it
to a domain or example application that
we're gonna run through and that
application is a cloud file storage app
so if that term doesn't really make too
much sense to just essentially think of
a service like Dropbox something where
you can store files on the Internet
anyways we're gonna look at two main
ways of building a cloud file storage
app and the app that I developed
recently I was decentralized was one of
these so we're gonna focus in on that
one so that's the more mysterious one
the one that probably you're not so used
to so anyways how this talk is gonna
break down is first we're gonna talk
about the what and the why like why
would you even mess around with a
decentralized thing and then from there
the how is the kind of the bulk of the
talk we're gonna cover trying to build
some features but essentially we're just
gonna be exploring the problems and
possible solutions when you go about
approaching a decentralized app and
finally gonna allude to this project
that kind of inspired this talk all
right so to get everyone on the same
page of first one I talked about the
client-server model in case you haven't
heard of it I'm just gonna go over it
briefly this is not peer-to-peer or
decentralized at all this is the normal
way of developing a web application and
if you've ever touched server-side code
or even hit an API if you just done
front-end stuff you've worked under this
paradigm and yeah just a browser going
as a client hitting a server and
delivering response is that type of
model so anyway now that that's where
we've got that covered I want to talk
about the client-server model in context
within the context of cloud file storage
so most cloud file storage
providers today use the client-server
model to build their features and
deliver their the system that you're
able to use to store files and download
them later at your leisure
this is fine that works pretty darn well
and but they have a property in common
that I didn't really think about before
I worked on this project which is that
their their centralized and that just
means that this service requires central
coordination and control in order to
work so you can just think of Dropbox's
authentication feature you don't worry
about people accidentally running into
your files on the internet they have
implemented an authentication system for
you and it's pretty darn reliable this
is a choice though for how you design
your system so let's consider what
centralization does let's go through a
list of pros and cons first it's kind of
a familiar development model you can
probably work a bit faster in this way
but there may be some cons so first this
is a quote from Mark Zuckerberg at a
congressional hearing when asked if he
could just you know freely share
Facebook data about whoever with whoever
and you know the answer is kind of like
essentially yes so I guess we're you
know supposed to trust them not to do
that but it might be the case that this
is an instance where if you can do it
it's probably happened before either
accidentally or on purpose second data
security there's there's kind of this
essential problem where when you gather
large amounts of useful information
valuable data and centrally store it
people may and probably will come for it
you don't know if they're the government
hacker cats ninjas you know we just know
that they're gonna come and finally
anonymity is a final con we're gonna
talk about and so there's some great
reasons to want to be anonymous on the
internet but there are also some
not-so-great reasons but that's not this
what this talks about what this talk is
gonna be about is we noticed that these
three cons they all kind of have a trust
component to them so what that means is
there we are relying on some third party
like a service provider or our
government
be a good player and not abuse their
access to our data we don't own the keys
to it although that's not something you
maybe think about every day but what if
we were more like Mulder and Scully what
if we trusted no one
what what would a trustless system look
like so it it might look to centralize
that could be one approach and this
looks pretty promising you know there's
like extra lines everywhere but how does
that actually address that our trust
issue I'm gonna we're gonna start
comparing centralized and decentralized
systems to try and explore that question
so the first thing is these kind of
decentralized systems visualized on the
right they don't have any central
authority and when we remove that
central authority we have Trant we
effectively transition from the
client-server model to something where
we have peers and peers and other peers
connecting on a network and at a more
practical level we no longer are dealing
with clients and one or more servers
we're dealing with these clients server
nodes that are autonomous so we'll
explore that a little bit more first at
just a turning terminology note may use
like node and peer and device
interchangeably but they all can kind of
refer to one of two things either a
personal device like a laptop or a mote
server we buy digitalocean or Amazon or
whoever
so we it's kind of like complicated to
figure out where to start
you know we have this decentralized idea
but where do we go from there so a good
place to start is maybe the simplest
cloud file storage system we can make
let's just try building something see
what happens so here's the definition
that I you know completely made up
full disclosure about what the most
basic cloud file storage system might be
might be something where you can upload
your file to the to the cloud delete
your own file locally but still be able
to get that same file later and because
we're talking about decentralized
systems we're gonna add in a final
requirement is that its peers only if we
had to put up a sign and say no servers
no clients
okay so now that we know where to start
building we're gonna start with this
upload process and we're gonna walk
through each of these steps in the
following slides but the central idea
right now is we're trying to get away
for a owner node to transfer a file to a
host node now this may actually kind of
look like a centralized system right
it's it's just two entities on a network
but in fact their peers so maybe another
way you know to describe it they're
they're equal an autonomous they don't
have neither of them have extra
privileges over the other another way of
maybe looking at it is this is node 1 on
the Left node 2 on the right we can
completely switch their roles because
their role flexible a client-server node
is the same thing as like a host owner
node we could also describe it that way
that's made more reflective of our
domain this is this is a node meet up so
I maybe should've used triple equals but
it's alright so let's get started we the
host creates a TCP server there's a
callback that has some logic in it that
will address later and then on the owner
side they're also going to create a TCP
server and afterwards connect to the
host they do so by connecting on the
same port as the host and whereas before
they connected on their own port finally
once that's done they're able to send
messages and data over to the other node
this host that's already created their
server is now once it receives that data
event and check the message type and
download the file locally so we've kind
of we've done it we've made a super
basic system but it's probably not that
good it's probably it's like a good
worst cloud storage system because I
mean if it's not super clear right now
this is a really bad system for storing
your files reliably and we'll go over
that shortly so this system is highly
likely to fail if there's anything
happens with the host our file is toast
you could say so
what do we do about that what we do is
we need to expect failure with our
system and we can't just like ruminate
on the fact that it's gonna fail we need
to design the system so that it can fail
effectively and heal itself let's talk
about a metaphor if that sounded like
mumbo-jumbo so this is allies have it's
world war two the Allies of landed in
Europe this looks like a really complex
operation right like there's a little
guy like freakin Zeppelin's and stuff so
there's a lot of resources a lot of
planning a lot of control so this is it
it could be like a large system maybe
something we can think of it like an
Internet giant with their application
that provides services for millions of
people sometimes people wonder like why
does Facebook have so many engineers
because a big system requires a lot of
work but the thing I want to talk about
is some systems don't require as much
central coordination here's an image of
paratroopers that may be in preparation
for Allied landing in Europe landing
behind enemy lines there it's chaos
right like they're landing everywhere so
what they did is they just everyone knew
their appropriate mission and they were
able to form their groups themselves and
go and execute independently they didn't
need central control so let's think
about what a better take these ideas and
think about what we how we could use
them to make a better cloud file storage
that was still decentralized but maybe
more feature comparable with something
like Dropbox we need to essentially
solve these four problems that we that
we haven't yet at all
we actually don't really have time to
solve them but let's solve this one at
least it's got some interesting
subproblems and yeah I think it'll be a
good ride so let's talk about how to
ensure file privacy it's pretty simple
concept only you should be able to see
your files only you should be able to
update or delete them if you wish so
when we let's look at how the two
systems approach the the two central
like development models approach this
type of challenge one is probably pretty
familiar to you its authentication
it's you know if we have different
clients connecting to a central server
and they're exchanging files each client
maintains access to its own separate
file they don't kind of get in the mix
however that's completely different in a
decentralized system in a decentralized
system everyone has access to everyone
else's files potentially so what our
goal should be is to make physical
access for lack of a better term to a
file useless instead it's sent to the
correct party so we'll explore how to do
that here are the two it's like two
layered approach that we're gonna be
using to do this and file sharding maybe
a little less familiar to you but we'll
get to it shortly first we'll talk about
encryption if a owner does not have
their own key they need to generate one
and once they have generated one then
they're able to encrypt their files now
we have effectively client-side
encryption and because it happens before
the file goes over the wire and we're
only dealing with one key so it's
symmetric encryption so upload process
better'n and our download process is
safer as well
we have hosts that can't read files that
they've been given physically that's
very different from a centralized system
you should never get file you should
access to file you don't have access to
I've been given access to and but the
owners are still able to read them next
we want to think about extra-extra
failure right we because it's kind of
risky to give files to random strangers
so what if a host actually gets access
to our key what do we how do we respond
to that potential eventualities
well file sharding is going to be our
answer to that first starts off by
splitting up a file into smaller pieces
and then we give each file a name a
unique name based on the hash of the
contents of that shard from there we
have this new upload process and it's a
bit safer I guess the host now has a
couple pieces of a file to deal with
we've also made our own lives pretty
difficult
we've now
don't can't guarantee the order of the
content when we pull it back down
we've disassociated the name from the
content itself so if we dealt with
multiple files would be completely
unfeasible so what we're gonna have to
do is think of a way to organize that
better we're gonna do that with a thing
called manifest files so manifest files
are going to help us retain order of our
shards and also keep the file name and
the shards in order and keep track of
them as well here we can see simple JSON
like object in a file and we don't need
to worry about we can do this without
databases which is nice so we're back
still to our problem of keeping these
files extra safe and the central issue
is we have all of our eggs in one basket
all pieces of a file are being stored by
one host additionally what if we give
like a movie file to this host you know
then they don't want to offer that much
space so they don't even have that much
space
that's not even gonna work so what we
have to do is spread out the storage
burden some how that's gonna complicate
our lives more but it's gonna make our
system way more effective so let's think
about how would we do that where are we
gonna send our shards as we send them
all the one node percent couple like how
do we do this it's not yeah
those were gonna be a problem for our
system so we're still trying to think of
a way that we can distribute the load of
files across multiple nodes and say we
have a list we have like a bunch of
shards and we have a bunch of nodes
maybe we could just have a list and like
iterate through that list how would that
work so let's check out this master list
example seems okay we have four nodes
and four shards just boom boom boom send
them up there you could just do the
reverse to get them back down right but
we should think about some properties of
the system one is that all of our nodes
are autonomous and equal so they all
need their own node list so we're not
just dealing with one like master novus
we're dealing with n
masternode lists so that's getting to be
a bit of a pain a second curveball that
were should expect to happen is as our
system scales from like this is for what
if we had 4 million or 4 billion nodes
those would create really onerous data
storage burdens on each of the nodes I
wanted to participate in the system and
would be a nightmare to update so that
that systems not going to work so let's
think of another system but first we're
let's break down this problem a bit a
more central question might be where do
we store one shark which host should it
go that's we're trying to establish that
relationship and in order to do that we
could also think about the opposite
question once it's uploaded we also need
to be able to understand how we retrieve
that shard so if we think about
real-world examples if only there was a
like a system that we could access
arbitrary resources over long distances
mmm like the internet that might do that
I mean it happens to do it reliably we
need to be able to access the same
resource every time we go there so how
does that work there might be something
worth exploring there might be needed
there there might be some sort of
coordination or routing going on so
let's check out this classic interview
question what happens when you go to
google.com if my friend told me that if
you say something like well there's just
like wizardry and magic going on and
then you get to Google you know the
interview doesn't go so well but maybe
you know something a bit more maybe you
know about DNS and you know hey like you
just throw in a domain name spits back
out an IP address it's an instant lookup
thing right but actually it's it's not
quite that simple because the the DNS
it's not a single centralized database
it's distributed across zones and each
of those zones there's one or more
domains and each zone is managed by a
name server but you know anyways DNS
examples aside it's kind of interesting
right we've there's a distribution of
data across a tree so how does
deal with that seems like a similar
problem that we're facing well when they
do lookups
they do this kind of like iterative
lookup thing which is kind of
interesting they in a kind of simplified
example will always go to the root
server or name server and so on and they
do this based on a hierarchical
structure now our system doesn't have
any inherent like hierarchy to it but
this is still interesting this iterative
lookup idea and also this distribution
of data maybe we can make use of that
but let's think about the properties of
our system what's unique that we have we
don't have hierarchies what we do have
our IDs where shards have been given IDs
that's about as much as we have to work
with right now but ideas are pretty
cheap right so let's let's let's give
the nodes IDs as well right but how does
that help us build zones how does that
allow us to distribute data burdens
across the network
well another metaphor we have two people
on either sides of the US but we don't
have any centralized data or centralized
tools in order to reach them we don't
have Google we don't have even phonebook
say but we do let's give them phones
what would you do if you needed to find
someone in New York you might talk to
your friends you might but maybe you
don't have any friends in New York who
do you decide to talk to we need some
sort of like heuristic or metric in
order to choose the best person and most
likely you can't call all of your
friends and ask about this one random
dude they might get weirded out but you
can maybe have take the time to ask one
person so let's actually just check the
person most eastward in hopes that we
eventually get someone in New York and
then someone else in New York City and
then that six degrees of Kevin Bacon
separation thing will kick in and we'll
get to him eventually
we can't really like guarantee the
minimum number of hops but we're going
to get closer and closer so
we're using a geographic metric for
closeness so let's think about a
closeness metric for IDs our closest
metric is going to be logical closeness
or so we're going where how we answer
the question where do we send a shard
and to which node so we're gonna send
the shard to the closest nodes ID to the
original shards ID maybe that didn't
make too much sense but the answer more
specifically is we're going to take the
XOR distance of each nodes ID now if
your bit manipulation skills are bit
rusty
here's like some examples it's not super
important there's like mathematical
definitions and bit definitions but this
is the one I use like if we're looking
at two values say ones and zeros the
these two rules on the right are going
to determine when we get a one back
anyway a quick example with some
simplified IDs so these are like
hexadecimal values here's some binary
ones that are bit simpler the first one
on the left is only one significant
digit and one bit different so it's at a
distance of one this one is that the
third significant digit so one zero zero
in binary in our real number system is
four so that's a distance of four so
that's that's interesting but we're
gonna need a lot more to get this whole
system working this is an interesting
idea but we're not there yet at all so
I'm just gonna skip to what we ended up
using we used a data structure and
protocol specification called Kadhim
Leah it's a flavor of distributed hash
table and it's used to power various
decentralized applications that are in
use today we did not want to code this
thing entirely ourselves there were
pre-existing libraries and there's a
actually a really great one in nodejs
called cadence if this is something
interesting to you I definitely
encourage you to check it out so next we
are going to look a little bit more at
what could emiliya does it for each node
in the network it has a routing table
which is a tree of buckets within
a certain bit space and each bucket
contains or otherwise referred to as k
bucket holds k number of contacts these
are interesting details but there's a
lot more questions about how would this
system work and it would take honestly a
lot of time to explain so to answer
these questions I'm not gonna do it
we're just just gonna black box this for
now and just like hop over that rabbit
hole and yeah but let's return to our
system we've implemented kadhi Maliha
it's going pretty great and here we've
got the first benefit we have smaller
lists or buckets or whatever we want to
call them this was the master list idea
before and we now instead of having n
sizeless
we have logged in so that's a big
improvement and this has allowed us to
also distribute storage across the
network which has increased its
flexibility and that in turn has allowed
us to store large files on the network
so uploading a movie file is now at
least feasibly possible where it was
previously gonna be very very unreliable
excuse me so I've come a long way from
our super simple super ineffective
system that we created earlier and I
want to take a brief detour from the
building to talk about the kind of the
project that inspired it myself and a
couple other friends made something
called lair and we went we built similar
feature set to what we've talked about
today but in terms of the file ownership
we also built other features as well
that unfortunately don't think we're
gonna have time to talk about today but
they were definitely very interesting I
could yeah this is us we're distributed
team we first met through an online
learn to code program a while ago and
kept in touch and I was in previously in
Portland and Tanner is now in New York
flow is here in the bay so yeah we could
do a quick demo of
it's not the best quality but what's
happening here is person uploading it
Tanner is using a CLI to upload a JPEG
to the network and it is generating low
shards locally and also each of these
shards is encrypted and there's also a
map like an entire encrypted file and
here just to demonstrate it's working
the file the local files are being
deleted and we're again using the the
CLI and in this case the list the El
flag to see all of the manifest files
that we've generated then we use the
manifest file to pull it back down
locally again and we have a file again
and it works
there's also that's it we'll just do
this patching one real quick
this is videos too fast but what's
happening is this person has executes a
patch command and an audit has failed so
this file did not have enough redundancy
I actually kind of regret showing this
video because we didn't really get to
those topics yet but it proved to you I
wasn't just making it up but if you
really want more proof more
understanding of what we did I really
encourage you to check out this blog
post that we are more like project
overview that we did that goes in detail
of how we built the different features
and our thought processes ease it kind
of mirrors the style of this talk so if
you found that interesting you can
definitely check that out
and finally I also wanted oh yeah
mention that there are some links that
you might find useful we did kind of
skip over the just a lot of details
we've distributed sister decentralized
systems and academia finally uh yeah I'm
looking for my next team so you can find
more information about me here or you
can talk to me in person about
centralized systems or anything so
thanks for listening and dealing with
the difficulties
[Applause]
yeah the network Oh a decentralized
system
so there's yeah so the question was by
the network did I mean the the
blockchain network so there's a couple
different functionalities going on here
one is just the upload and download of
files that's just when I when I use the
word Network in that context I just mean
the Internet like we are able to create
in our case just TCP servers and then
have files be transported back and forth
across participating nodes on the
network you may have seen something
later on where I threw up in the like
kind of incentives part of the project
that there was we wanted to make it so
that you know this is not just like a
free writer system like maybe there
could be some underpinning technology
that makes people want to participate in
offer up space or not and in that case
we did hook that up to a test net or may
like a test wallet using stellar so that
had some crypto tie-ins there but it was
completely you know it's just test net
stuff
[Music]
yeah yeah this isn't like a hosted
service you can use today if you really
want to get rid of Dropbox you'd have to
like make your own community around it
and if this type of storage is something
interesting to you there are two
companies at least I know of that I
neglected to mention that we're all so
we're kind of inspirations for this
project one is called Storage spelled
sto RJ and they have a great white paper
that we referenced when building a lot
of our features a second one is called
file coin and yeah it's decentralized
cloud file storage kind of similar to
the system we talked about today my
question is you taken the users data
distributed over a bunch of networks but
the code that actually controls
everything is being billed by one
institution so in a way it still there's
a central centralization that people
have to trust the company
- yeah so I I'd neglected to do one
thing which is leave out a keyword this
is a completely experimental project
only us when we're messing around with
the system are using this in a file
storage e way so yeah it's I agree with
you that when people are making
decentralized systems you probably need
to check in on that company as well but
that wasn't an issue we faced here yeah
are you using open source just kind of
piggyback off this question are using
that idea that it's open source that you
don't control the code or which you
closed it because I'm a little
comfortable using open source yeah so in
the blog post we actually say like this
is really interesting it's an
experimental project we've been working
on would incur it's up on github and
open source and if you want to
contribute to it that's great if you
want to you know do whatever you want
with it because it's open source that's
also great but we probably wouldn't
recommend it as a viable stable way to
store very important personal files for
you right now because it's you know at
any given time like right now there are
zero people supporting it you need sort
of a critical mass to get something like
this working so if you have a lot of
friends with a lot of servers lying
around you know might be able to work
something out I'd definitely be fun but
yeah right now the open so close source
thing I would kind of recommend asking
the people that are you know running
this as a professional service where
they want to ask for serious money from
people in the future how they would
approach that type of issue yeah
how does this compare to big-time drive
so BitTorrent um oh the torrent drive I
was gonna answer one way but then yeah
that's the same thing yeah I'm
completely unfamiliar with that system
but if I had to guess based on their
previous work and also you so
[Music]
you know gang suppression
yes to turn of the world population is
disconnected yeah exactly
yeah that I mean I'm not an expert on
blockchain at all and I actually did the
least amount of work on the blockchain
stuff for this project but there are a
number of other pros and cons to this
type of system that I wasn't able to
talk about today because I mean there's
just so much to talk about but one of
them is that if you make decentralized
think ipfs is talking about this their
company that's also doing the file coin
thing and they want to make the
decentralized internet so instead of
most we kind of take for granted that a
lot of our services that we enjoy our
say like based in San Francisco we have
really low latency costs because we're
located very close to these valuable
services people living in other
countries that are very far away are not
necessarily so fortunate so they're kind
of exploring how to you know maybe
improve that latency Store for people in
more rural regions and I think actually
this technology might have some
applications there as well we kind of if
you're relying on storage being close to
you like we do here to be very fast
that's not a luxury that people in other
countries can necessarily enjoy so there
might be some applications there as well
[Music]
yeah it's great question it's a simple
engineer so I don't have all the answers
problem sir
I demand an answer we got right back huh
did you have something no I think I
think that was our last question cool if
you want to ask him some more please
come up